hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to treasure hunter simulator
i'm assuming this is the type of game
where we
go around the world and we take things
that weren't ours and call it treasure
that's how imperialism works
anyway or it's buried treasure that's
long forgotten and it's totally ours to
take
story mode let's go story mode i want to
know exactly what i'm doing here
and why i'm doing it welcome to treasure
hunter this is a tutorial level
and this will teach you how to play and
find treasures quickly and effectively
am i in some kind of a war am i gonna
oh no no oh no what am i digging up
what soldier's tomb am i am i about
oh
oh wow
now that's really something that's a
slice of something special
yeah this looks like sacred ground the
kind that i shouldn't
be tampering with then again national
treasure is a
national treasure of a movie so i can't
really criticize it so if
this is me breaking into the lincoln
memorial or something i guess it
wouldn't be too bad you know
they just discovered that there's a
whole chamber beneath the lincoln
memorial or maybe they didn't just
discover it i just discovered that so
i'm going to be exploring down there
no pda
[Music]
here you'll find a top-down view of your
current location with important
landmarks marked
the map will update with locations that
you managed to find a treasure
is there a treasure right there do i spy
a treasure by this sacred monument
do i spy oh oh
oh i'm really finding something
okay we're close oh yeah baby
oh yeah it's gonna be like some gold
teeth from a skull
here here isn't it here
got it mine oh mine
who cares about this sacred battleground
that was fought and bled upon
this treasure is mine
i'll take that please what is this
oh an old necklace it looks val is this
a locket does it have like
someone's dearly beloved that they wrote
a very somber message to dearly beloved
i pray that war ends soon and that i
find myself in your arms again
hopefully some schmuck a hundred years
from now doesn't take this from me
should i die today oh yeah spray that
spray it was a beautiful gift for a
beloved girl
she's dead now or the love is broken
which in case this is mine now either
way
condition is tolerable all right cool
first steps
man man i feel good about this
said there was something over here right
yeah someone over here maybe not maybe
not there are no treasures nearby yeah
you're right about that
oh what are these tombstones i bet they
have something special over here
this feels skeezy this feels key
[Music]
am i detecting something
oh yes oh no hang on hang on
we're on to something
oh it's here somewhere oh oh oh oh
nice i hope it's another locket of lost
love what is this
what is that oh what is that identify
it's a ruined iron button great
well metal other you mean iron buttons
have been already in use in ancient rome
but there are older examples like around
china in
2000 who made the first button man they
had been on to something
along with the wheel and fire
oh mama whoa mama whoa mama
whoa mama got some
some groundskeeper is going to come by
just like a bunch of holes dug
oh look it's the key from a heist with
markiplier identify
spraying these horrible chemicals onto
the field here killing all the grass
i feel good about me it's a key
all right good oh boy more
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh
where was it where was it i found it i
saw it it's mine dibs
nibs dibs on this dibs on this dibs on
the memories
oh how did i find this is this a needle
what is that there's a needle all right
i really did it guys
guys i did it oh i got it apparently
all right cool how more can i deface
this lovely park how more how more can i
i'm already at the peak just
yes yes yes i
feel it i feel it i feel it i'm really
gonna hit the big one this time
[Music]
i'll take that a coin was that is it a
coin
no no no an old medallion depicting the
blessed virgin mary well i mean that's
pretty cool
it's gold it's only worth 10 but it's
gold sounds pretty good to me
10 bucks a bunch of baloney i guess i
just
oh legendary each zone you visit will
also have a special treasure called a
legendary
these items are very rare and can only
be found if you get some tips where to
look
once found identified and stored a
legendary item will greatly increase
your prestige
within the treasure hunter society
there's a society
that's a society oh boy is that to do
with the uh the this here
i should have known by the big obelisk
here
well i might as well you know i might as
well
but
dib harder this is a bullet casing
no that was yeah it's a bullet casing
hmm the police will be interested in
about this
all right good now there's something
over here maybe i should just
there are no treasures nearby are you
sure about that you said that there
would be a legendary treasure
and i'm here to find it something right
here oh no historical object
okay whatever okay how did you say i
could go return to office here we go
large spaces you can walk freely around
the office
and you'll find a pc and collections to
interact with ah yes
my collection this is quite an office
this is god this is such an office
where do i live what kind of castle ass
castle do i live in
sometimes i just like to walk around my
office and look at all of my possessions
hmm look at this coins
yes my wealth all mine i got it fair and
square
hmm okay so i i still need to collect
obviously those are empty but someday
they'll be surging with wondrous
treasures from around the world
around the world all right bavarian lake
travel cost free in what world is travel
free all right whatever what's this uh
good morning my name is johanns
schmidt i'm writing you as a
representative of the willpower
inheritance company we regret to form
you that your uncle sir richard
clapperton
it's not funny very sad has deceased i
am sending this message to inform you
that we are starting the inheritance
case following sir richard's wishes i am
also providing your email address to a
selected number of contacts that will
follow a different set of rules provided
in the last will
what rules are you talking about one
year from now these contacts will be
asked to provide a full review of your
actions
and based on them we'll be able to wire
the part of your inheritance that sir
richard wished to give you
what kind of puzzle-ass puzzle
oh rumors of it being the resting place
of
hitler's gold something tells me i don't
want hitler's gold because something
tells me it might not have been
hitler's you know what i mean okay jobs
cleaning up
a thousand prestige well that's nice
what am i doing i'm just cleaning
is this what i'm all right you know what
i'll do it i guess i'm looking for
hitler's gold
i guess that's what i am doing today i
didn't wake up thinking that i would be
looking for hitler's gold but here i am
all right let's get a lay of the land
here wow oh yeah this is cool
i mean very pretty well the water's
looking
a little 2005 but you know it's okay
it's all right it's still look at that
that's still pretty
okay oh
apparently i'm in a children's mystery
novel oh
wait what do we have here some goodies
oh oh oh oh where was that oh
man it's these spots are tiny is this
hitler's gold
what is this what is it
a metal fastener was attached to a frame
of folding chairs
oh i found a folding chair part uh am i
gonna find hitler's gold is it you know
that would be quite the story you know
someone just came out here
to clean up not for much money but you
know prestige
and uh just happened to stumble upon
hitler's gold okay this must be a sign
you look at
h there's no i but there's an i in
team so together you look beyond the
left and the right and you go straight
forward
hitler's gold oh my god oh my god oh my
god hitler's gold
i'm not excited about it i swear gosh
i'm not excited about it
oh oh i found it i found it i found the
gold
[Music]
it's a button well that was fun you know
i had a good time with that what's with
the
there must be a clue yes is a clue is a
clue
where the light of the sun doth shine
like
gold shall you find the resting place
oh so old and when all of the legends
we're told
that is where your soul is
sold because it's cursed because it's a
it's cursed hitler
no okay it's probably just going to be
trash because i'm guessing that this
mission is going to lock me into just
finding nothing but
well garbage yeah garbage okay once you
find a button
upon the ground
only then can it
be found
so good dibs on this probably garbage
considering it's on the path i'm just
going to assume that it's garbage
oh it's a bullet casing okay without a
doubt a 9 by 19 millimeter
a luger german world war one
not quite world war after world war one
who's screaming flowers oh
follow the screams they'll lead you
there
but don't but but what
but be careful you best beware
lixian make that seem cohesive okay cool
make it seem like i actually can rhyme
you know i can rhyme you know we all
know i can rhyme right
well i mean they will all know when i do
rhyme
i hate to say it but i'm actually having
a good time
you know what i mean it's kind of
satisfying i guess
oh my god how much useless crap is there
here okay i did my quest is there any
other
point of me being here i don't know
there's like like actual things here but
i don't think i'm gonna fight guys i
hate to say it but i don't think i'm
gonna find hitler's gold so i'm just
gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna call this a day well
done
all right you know i was kind of having
fun but also i start i'm starting to
realize that oh find a lead musket
bullet in good
condition in the gettysburg oh that was
gettysburg oh
[Laughter]
good good good
good good you know now i'm gonna go for
hitler's goal
i got a real good feeling about this
time guys i was thinking up some more
rhymes that were really gonna get me
where i needed to go
cross the bridge where the woodnot creek
take a look take a peek
over the hills and through the woods
there you'll find people who are up to
no goods
nazis that was about nazis i'm assuming
i mean poems are up to interpretation
sometime but i'm going to assume them in
nazis
you can never know you never know
you never know he'll lose gold
in the shadow of the hill there you'll
find
the way to pay my bills oh mama
when i don't see anything i see nothing
i see absolutely
nothing oh it's a bottle cap if you wait
until 2077 it might
okay cool okay this is going to be the
one guys
this is i can feel it in my voice
when you feel it in your bones
you will be able to buy all of the
scones
what do you think this guy's like family
history really was
who is this uncle does he actually have
any sort of inheritance because i don't
seem to make
pretty much anything a very old gold
coin oh
i said what did i say a ghbr
rearrange the letters and what do you
get
maybe not hitler's gold but hey a gold
coin that's pretty good 120 bucks
i'm gonna assume that this is better
than hitler's gold because it's
not hitler's remains of old
what did i do what have i been told
did i find hitler's gold
i'm cursed and cursed forever everyone
and cursed oh boy a bottle cap okay all
right cool
well that's great what is with these
this is the path of gold could it be
look deep within the lush of
brush don't tell a soul
nary a hush
uh and that's the end of the rhyme oh
i don't see anything i see literally
nothing
but i saw nothing oh it's a key okay
whatever
so what is with this what is with this
is this the road to go oh wait there's a
circle on that one
okay but what's with this
okay what's with this
oh i found it and it's uh pop tab by the
looks of it looks like a pop tab
looks like the top of them
[Music]
oh my god literally i'm just digging up
the trash that beat these people threw
out oh
boy you find one piece of hitler's gold
and you think you're gonna find the rest
it's my fault for not looking where i
found the first piece of gold you know
my fault my fault what is that
rifle cartridge rifle cartridge all
right
i've identified it world war ii
we're getting closer bling i found bling
okay you this
there's something here oh there's a
treasure nearby all right
i'm detecting a hint of gold give me
your gold
open the door where's hitler's gold i
don't know
hitler is that you in there oh
it's you isn't it oh you can't run
[Applause]
forever
by the dock it's a lock
something you could fit inside your sock
that's a needle 10 bucks for a needle
you
can bend a needle out of shape and go to
someone to be like hey
i found this needle it'll point you in
the direction of hitler's goal what is
this about
something's going on here so okay some
something's going on here whenever
there's an x
it means treasure you can always know
you always know
coin coin or button is it a coin or a
button
pointer button ah it's a blah it's a
hitler's button nah it's out just a damn
button
okay whatever so this has got to mean
something this has to mean something
this this like has to there's no way
that doesn't mean something
it either means like it's dead ahead or
something or oh i can't even go that way
oh it's all blocked off or that's just
like a symbol
telling construction crews to maybe you
know no x's mean treasure
treasure hello dragonfall i
if this is in hitler's gold i will give
up
my treasure hunting days forever
well wasn't hitler's gold okay well i'm
good i'm going back to the office
i think i did my job here find the
picklehob
the picklehub of course
the secret name for hitler's gold
the helmet all right one last travel to
the bavarian lake
one last trip okay so it was at the back
of some house but i'm betting it's not
these i'm betting it's this one
i'm ignoring everything until i get to
the helmet
nope i'm ignoring it i'm ignoring you oh
oh oh there's some kind of bear up there
a bear
a bear look for the bear there you'll
find
if you dare the the gold the gold it's
been told
everyone knows the gold is so cool
yes yes the butterflies the flutterbyes
where the butterflies do flutter by it's
that seems improbable wow look at that
spike look at it oh wow it's pristine
holy oh look at that
what is that spray priceless
i really do wonder was this practical
like did people
you know i mean did people you know
you know like you know
sorry lixian please yes
i did it sorry uh hitler i guess we're
done
and there's the helmet great that's good
glad that's on my desk so
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to go treasure
hunting
links in the description maybe you'll
have better luck than i but i had
incredible luck so i doubt you'll ever
beat me
because i'm amazing so thank you and as
always i will see you
in the next video bye
[Music]
you